ポッポー呑気でいいなぁ
俺は今から
命をかけますこんにちははじめ社長です皆さんと詐欺格闘ブームらの知っています
でしょうか
youtube とかで見ても格闘家で youtube やってるとすごい多くて
打つそそんな物騒な格闘ノイズバーがたくさんいるんですけどもうその中でも特に物騒
なのが朝倉みくるアイスだけはなぜでや0
めちゃくちゃ25朝倉満さんもめちゃくちゃ cgi
動画が大きく見せて格闘機普通に強い子ですけど勝ちたいところなんだしてかつたいと
思ってしまったんですよ私はに方に来てて今からコラボが取るんですけどもないような
ちょっと丸めの同い年なんですよ同じ歳トークしましたみたいですね丸い丸い感じで
やってるんですけども息をついて
普通の格闘スキルできなくで勝てないんで彼を倒すために
わっふいうち不意打ちで倒すしかないんですよ金属のバトル店それで3部さんは上なん
でアイスを倒すためにはもう不意打ちで街並を3周をしますこれからタイラー的な番は
結果普通に代わって話してみすっげをついてバイコーン
一発で沈めますよねすごい g 今年がわかってるんですけどもアサクロ3キロちょい
はこれしかねいつはまあの格闘中
というわけでやらテリー若年グローブ準備しますたファイラーする時に座るベッド
スティックしておきますこれで本当にいい感じで年か朝倉に来ると話して調子乗ってる
ところの開通の顔面にキーパーこう言って
白桃ユーチューバートッポス倒したいそれが今日の俺の狙いですね y 5
[音楽]
あでご注意します
と普通自
させだけど
ですはい全然ある
車
この感じで始めですこんな感じだったのでずっとつかはいというわけで今日は実はない
ですし
朝ケアできるさんねー
始めますねはじめの子ですね
どこだか動画ですごいみたいなのでいや僕もですよ
本当ですかはいはじめましての漢字を知らせ僕はです全然なくてもヤンキーボコってる
イメージからああ
ヤンキーじゃないですけどそうなのか麻倉みなさんなんて youtube はじめた
んですよ
それこそ格闘広めたいなっていうとあとまあ自分たちで種別の楽しい者ですか
うん
昔からこう上昇がに命令されクリアと
おいてくるさん持ってます僕は姉
持っていると思うんですけどそういう場にあんま行かないですね温度がもし合うこと
ないし
ま実感そうですから普通に生きてて女人に出会うことがないんで正直持てればとファン
も考えてお金も誰も同じはどこなんですよね
持ってるでしょ
野草せないでも dm 度がめっちゃ
こないんですよそれが思ったことをいいムードが返したいですか
何の場だっけこれお会いできて本当に良か
たぶんそんなありえないと思ってると思うけどして下さ
私がほらほらぼくもわんこブログ受けてくれるんって言う
そこで big city かけチョコ大好きなんですよ
ここがあったからねはい
嬉しいです
ブーバーと
ロセアンかナイフ
せぬ不1位ピュッ夏絶対わかんないんですよ
視聴者それじゃあ盛り上がってますけどこれから
をくるさんは趣味とかなんかあるんですかこれ書くとどうかお仕事以外で何されてるの
かなというのはそこ
スレ主3勤可能
将棋とかえっ消費いるんですか粧裕はせるとか詐欺一方かと思います
あぁ好きです
ゲームとかやられないんだけど
競馬でもこのなの時はスイッチ言えましょうあまりよああ
マリオ結構2をクリアしました突っ込め買う積もりました
桃鉄とかじゃないですか桃鉄でませんえっ
もので釣れないかも鉄で何もボタンさを持ったローゼンですと言う
ネックすごろくゲームみたいに打って人生ゲームに朝ジェットで
いうスイーツ最近でたんですけど阿蘇役に立つべきやすいでしょうライト攻
barbie 系てほしいですか
バーベキューを比較的苦手ですにはて少ない分ございます
年配づらいから授けところこの
七輪とカオスんです
するこんくらいの月で
今回の形で3人くらいでいいんですけど香月もラベル sa
自分たちに合ってた女だから大江いいですね
いいましょうありませんでしょ t シャツです
ゲームですねゲームちょっときついな端からと帰っているさせながらってか強いですよ
あの6円の挿抜安町北やんか
6洋もうすぐ前灯台ですよ形はされますやってますです今どうなんだろう
強かったと思いますけど64のスマブラって対決しましょうでしょ
8ジョイ車チャンネルで64のスマブラに来て
7シリーズ入って作るや仕切りで語ってみたぱーい ff
くるさんの
今後の youtube の目標と勝手な花です
今後の youtube の目標はよねぼくような気候言ってるけど有名になりたく
ない派だぞ
テレビとかまでたくないと思う一つ店大手広告はさせてい
もともと tv やりたくないんだけど1 u 広めたいと自由の仕事っていうので
初めてありますよね
一番最初の動画でも有名じゃないんですけど
マジですか
なんだけど
選ぶ僕自由を求めている
もともとなんかよく覚え各じゃないしたの明日かわいい
ていけるはいそういうでいなかったんで
あの始めたんですけど
あの
チーク自由じゃなくなる-1知名度はちょっと確かにマップやありますよ
それはいつでも見られているか
th
どうしましたじゃあねっ
me
マッハワンですか
スプーンなぁ
ああああああああ
壊れましたーーー
[音楽]
ブーバーし
はぁ
しかも感覚入ってないですよ
知っています
あっちにもあったんですはい
さあ ing なうん
僕がただの対談なんてするわけないじゃないですかいやあもうねあらしいなと思ってい
ます
徒歩で時祝べき人って少ないです僕もちょっと怖かったんです
もどったんですけどミキュレさんに勝つにはこれしかねぇだと思っ
まずめな対談2に朝からみくるに殴りかかってきたところ
なるほど今日お正月とっては新鮮するがチェスダイスですがちょっとんというのが
起こってないけど
おもてなしことですいやいけそうだったんだけど
本当に行くんだったらウケるいいと思います
そこへば格闘技なる各当事者にとりわけで
朝倉みくるさんと台湾
はいはいまんですけど浅く予備軍さんに退団チート前半10点も勝てないことが今回
分かりました
ございますっ
すーっ
ああああああ